I have to tell you the truth we were
very very blessed that once my son was
born I'm not saying it was easy because
it's very challenging Leah Michelle
shares an update on her son ever after
the two-year-old was hospitalized for a
scary health issue we were so scared I
was terrified on Wednesday Leah revealed
that her little one was admitted to the
hospital she didn't explain the issue
but said that she needed to take some
time away from her Broadway play funny
girl to tend to her son Leah asked fans
for their love and strength well fast
forward to Friday and seems like the
Good Vibes worked because the triple
threat announced Evers going home I'm
very happy yeah here's little ever in
bed clutching a stuffed animal Leah
thanks her fans for their well wishes as
well as the amazing doctors and hospital
staff every day truly with my son
whether or not it's an exhausting day a
challenging day we're so grateful
especially because of everything that we
went through to have him in our life now
it means so much to me but there's even
more good news Leah's heading back to
the stage can we skip to the good part
yep Leah confirms after taking a few
nights off she'll return to her starring
role as Fannie Bryce don't bring her on
a clatter to Rain on My Parade
he's like Mama and he goes I said
Mommy's at work and he goes ah and I
said yep I'm gonna I'm gonna sing
I know he knows
Leah and her businessman husband Zandy
Rich welcome their son in August 2020. I
had to have a lot of very terrifying
procedures and hospital visits during my
pregnancy in the midst of the pandemic
and I would just I just remember
gripping his hand and it it was that I'm
so grateful for the strength that he had
to help me get through it all the couple
tied the knot in March 2019 after dating
for a couple years oh my gosh I my
husband is honestly the greatest he is
so wonderful he has a very grounded
strength and as far as future plans for
growing their family Leah told E.T this
after giving birth to ever the minute
they handed me my son I looked at my
husband and I said I'm ready to do this
again and he looked at me like I was
insane but I was so so happy in that
moment
foreign